[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في قلب التغيير النابض بالحياه
في السعوديه نجد ضباب شركه انتاج تشكل
جسرا بين صناعه السعوديه الخليجيه وهوليود
وتهدف لتسليط الضوئي على الثقافه الشرق
الاوسطيه هنا في عاصمه السينما ضيف اليوم
الكاتب والممثل السعودي هشام فقيه يبقوا
معي
[موسيقى]
هشام اني سعيد جدا بشوفتك وبهذا اللقاء
وكنت فخور هوايه من قريه المقال عنك
بصحيفه درايه العالميه وسعيد جدا بيكون
نجاحاتك والفروه ما شاء الله
اخذها بعد اللقاحات وانا اسعد حبيبي وشكرا
الله يسلمك
[موسيقى]
خلينا نخبر كل المشاهدين على التعاونك مع
جامعه usb وحده من اهم الجامعات
بكاليفورنيا ايش كنت تسوي انا يا طويل
العمر والسلامه بديت انا كمستشعار بدات
هذه المبادره
كمبادره التعليم يسموها او تبادل بين
الطرفين فحاولنا انه خلال المبادره هذه
اللي
هيتف انه احنا نهيئ منتجين وكتاب انهم
يتطور ويصيروا داخل العالم العربي خلينا
نمشي ونسولف بما انه تذكرت انه انت حابب
شركتك تكون الجسر بين هوليود والشرق
الاوسط خبرنا على اول المشاريع اللي حابه
تنفذها من خلال شركتك وايضا خبرني على
علاقه شركتك
اول شيء انا شريكي اخذ منحه او احنا كشركه
منها على مشروع التلفزيوني مسلسل جانرا او
مسلسل رعب
هال
وحتى زوجتي اول ما عرفتها قالت ايش علاقه
الكوميديا بالرعب فحاولنا انه احنا نعمل
فيلم او مسلسل عفوا يقوم احداثه بالعالم
العربي وبالسعوديه ويكون ملموس وبيكون
بمعايير
كخصصيا وسردين
فاتطور هذا الناس بامريكا وهو خريج جامعه
انوا ايو وانا بحكم تجربتي
والحمد لله برضو شافونا انه احنا مهيئين
عوضونا منحه واحنا الان في
خلينا نقول مفاوضات يعني بحيث انه كيف
احنا ممكن نقوم بهذا المشروع معهم
[موسيقى]
خبرني ايضا الى اي درجه شاركتك راح تنطي
الفرصه لكل المواهب السعوديه والعربيه انه
تيجي وتحقق حلمها على الصعيد عالميه شوف
اذا ان شاء الله ربي اعطانا العمر احنا
ناوينا ان احنا نفتح الابواب وبالعكس احنا
نستفيد شكرا جزيلا على هذا اللقاء هشام
حاب تقول اي شي لكل المشاهدين قبل الختام
صارت السينما ما في مثلها لانها هي تجربه
جماعيه في سماعيه
مثلا
تجربه احد يضحك او الجمهور يضحك بنفس
الوقت والجمهور يمسك نفسه في فيلم رعب هذه
تجربه فريده منها فلا تستصغروها وحاولوا
انكم تجربوها ومع كلام هشام شكرا جزيلا
على المتابعه وعوده الى استوديو لاستكمال
باقي فقره صباح العربيه